steel for man silver for the
supernatural these are the blades of a
witcher
if you've played red or watched the
witcher you'll know that geralt carries
two swords a steel one for non-magical
folk and a silver one for things that go
bump in the night but why is it silver
well we all know that silver kills
monsters that's just something that
fiction has implanted in our heads for
the best part of the last century but
what is it about silva that has given it
its mysterious supernatural power and
does that myth have any basis in fact
i've come here to the royal armies
museum in the uk to chat to jonathan
ferguson the keeper of firearms and
artillery as well as keith ducklin a
sword expert and historical interpreter
about the myths and realities behind the
silver sword using a silver soul would
be about as much good as trying to fight
someone with a stick of licorice so join
me as i untangle the facts from the
fiction and discover the true history
behind the witch's silver sword
[Music]
hi
great boy
what's the point of having two swords
a witch's silver sword is one of the
main tools of their gory trade a
specialized weapon built to destroy
monstrous creatures beasts and the
supernatural while the basic blade
itself isn't magical in nature the
properties of silver make it highly
effective against the mystical creatures
found in the world of the witcher with a
metal burning said beasts and preventing
them from healing silver swords your
best option for keeping them at bay
despite popular belief in both the
witcher lore and within the fan base the
sword is not wholly forged in precious
metals as read in the world of the
witcher compendium the core of the blade
as well as its edges is made from steel
coated in silver but the idea that
silver kills the supernatural is a
concept that is deeply woven into the
witch universe and like much of its deep
law it borrows from centuries of
european folklore but where exactly did
the myth of silva being a supernatural
slayer first emerge
whereas the trope of silva being a
monster killer is a relatively recent
phenomenon within pop culture the belief
in silva's mystical properties extends
far back into human history in ancient
times silver was seen as a very pure
metal with the ancient greeks romans
macedonians phoenicians and ancient
chinese using it to help purify their
food and water ancient greeks and romans
found that water stored in silver
pitches would stay purer for longer than
water kept in wooden or clay vessels and
silver coins were even placed in
containers of water and wine to keep
liquids fresh on long ocean voyages
silver was also widely used as a
medicinal tool within these ancient
civilizations as a substance that was
used to heal wounds and eliminate
bacteria and even the father of western
medicine hippocrates referenced the
healing properties of silver in 400 bc
this is because types of silver
naturally have antimicrobial properties
which makes a useful chemical across a
wide range of medicinal purposes some of
which are still being utilized today the
point i'm making is that silver even
from very early on in human history was
seen as a metal that could heal purify
and protect when you look at it from
that perspective it's easy to consider
why the silver as a metal could be used
to take on beasts and monsters
its use as a monster-slaying weapon
however emerged much later with a
handful of varying accounts appearing
across european folklore in 19th century
germany there were stories of hunters
fashioning silver bullets to dispatch
fearsome werewolves even the brothers
grimm tapped into the myth using the
concept in their 1812 fairy tale the two
brothers in this story a character's
three silver buttons are used as bullets
in order to shoot a witch but perhaps
the first known instance of silver
emerging as a weapon against evil was in
the 1700s with the infamous account of
the beast of gevowden a real-life tale
of man vs nature that saw one of the
earliest accounts of silver bullets
being used a topic a certain keeper of
firearms and artillery knows quite a bit
about the history of silver bullets for
shooting supernatural creatures or
entities
is probably very old it might be as old
as the gun itself the first firm
reference that that i've seen and i
certainly didn't discover it as a famous
incident was the case of the beast of
gevauda in france in the 1760s and it
was thought to be this giant beast if
you've ever seen the film brotherhood of
the wolf that's a
very sort of comic book take on this i
say real incident i mean it's thought to
have been maybe a pack of particularly
wild wolves if that makes sense like
starving wolves or something like that
and more than one creature but the myth
that developed was that it was one giant
killer wolf that was just terrorizing
the countryside killing all and sundry
and various people stepped forward sort
of slayer style to come in and kill this
thing and they actually tried different
bullets out on it so lead i believe tin
as well
and silver and it's not like still they
hit it it's not like a modern horror
movie where they discover silver works
and that's it i think they just
struggled to to pin this thing down but
nonetheless they did try silver which
shows that this was a known
substance to use
while the beast of gavowowdon was a real
account and was essentially a group of
human hunters shooting wolves with
whatever they could get their hands on
there is no denying the likelihood that
it inspired european folklore
surrounding werewolves folklore
surrounding lycanthropy and werewolves
was nothing new at the time of the beast
of gavowowdon but it was a constantly
evolving subject during that period
thanks mainly due to a slate of werewolf
trials that were held across europe
between the 15th and 18th centuries
naturally as werewolf fiction began to
take hold in the 19th and 20th centuries
this idea that werewolves held a
vulnerability to silva started to become
embraced more and more as part of the
fictional law this would go on to
further take hold in the world of cinema
with the concept of silver being a
werewolf killer as first seen in the
universal classic horror 1941's the wolf
man where the titular werewolf is beaten
to death using a silver-topped walking
cane
since its first cinematic appearance
silver bullets and the idea that silva
was a monster killer exploded thanks to
popular culture particularly through
werewolf movies like silver bullets the
howling and the leathercloud 2003
vampire vs werewolf series underworld
and not to be left out of this monster
mash vampires are also supposedly
susceptible to silver sunlight garlic
and crosses have been staples of vampire
killer fiction for hundreds of years but
the hammer horror movies from the 50s
60s and 70s started mixing in silver and
specifically silver bullets as a weapon
against the iconic dracula bullish man
a bullet cannot harm me
a silver bullet
dracula
blurring the lines between fiction and
reality even further the royal armories
actually have a vampire hunter's kit
featuring a pistol and a pair of silver
bullets although the set was later
discovered to be a prop replica likely
made as a result of the popularity of
the hammer horror movies the kit serves
as another reminder to the enduring myth
that silva is a successful weapon
against monsters a myth that really took
flight across the 20th century it takes
silver to kill a werewolf
and we were taking no chances
so now we've tracked the myth of
silver's power across the centuries from
folklore origins to our current pop
culture what does that tell us about the
witches and their silver swords
well naturally being set within a world
of dark medieval fantasy the battles are
mostly fought with bows and blades so
while it's not a silver bullet geralt's
silver sword still has the same power
legacy and recognition as a monster
killer the issue here is that silver is
an incredibly soft malleable metal a
metal that isn't fit to serve as a
cutting blade even one reinforced with a
steel core
using a silver saw would be about as
much good as trying to fight someone
with a stick of licorice the only useful
thing about it is it's so soft that you
could roll it up and put it in your
backpack when you were finished so it
would be hopeless as a as a fighting
weapon but of course he's not using it
to fight humans or monsters or people in
armor or anything in in the books you
know that is his his magic sword it's
his steel sword that he uses for the the
really serious work silva being a much
softer metal than steel makes the blade
of the weapon difficult to properly
sharpen and means it will always remain
somewhat delicate therefore clashing
against other blades or the armor of
your fellow man is not advised in the
witcher 3 at least this is reflected by
your silver sword doing less damage and
degrading more quickly when used against
brigands and bandits so while it's
established that a silver sword would in
no way make for a decent fighting weapon
it's interesting to note how the witcher
still tries to balance the pop culture
myths with a touch of reality even with
bronze swords early iron swords they
deform there are plenty of references in
roman literature in norse literature to
warriors swords bending out of shape and
in some cases you know they put it under
their foot they bend it back into the
shape and they keep on fighting but what
it shows you is that a soft blade even
one that is you know tough enough to
withstand a certain amount of of
battlefield rigor it gets bent out of
shape it becomes useless you won't
always have the time to bend it back
into shape so i think what we have to to
finish off by saying is yeah if this guy
is a zombie knight you know if he's not
made of flesh and bone and that's not
steel armor and he's just some kind of
manifestation then yeah i can probably
slice him i can stab him i can do what i
like with my silver sword but at the end
of the day
i think i'd still trust a good old steel
sword
so no unfortunately the silver sword is
not a feasible blade but it still holds
power as a unique and iconic weapon in
our pop culture the witch's own is an
armament that is held up by centuries of
folklore cinema and storytelling but
still succeeds in growing that myth and
creating a sword iconic to its own
stories as well as expanding the
profession of monster slayer within
wider pop culture whether from its use
as a healer and purifier in our real
history or as a weapon against beasts
and monsters in our fantasy silver is
anything but second best
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
hit the like button and subscribe for
more just like this and of course let me
know your thoughts in either the comment
section down below or reach out to me on
twitter at a regular dave if you want
more video game weaponry content you can
watch our previous series of this show
or check out our weekly series of expert
reacts where i show our friends at the
royal armories a selection of video game
arms to break down and make sure to come
back next week for a deep dive into one
of the most iconic weapons of the second
world war the m1 garand
until next time i've been your host dave
dewitt and i will see you in the next
episode
[Music]
you